the job of a father has one major job
keep his daughter off the pole that's it
you've heard this before like you're
like that's it like job done so how many
women that are on the pole in your girls
are stripping sex work only fans even
not that you're doing that would you say
have Daddy Issues it could be any time
to family issues I think is Major
trauma yes whenever it's Daddy Issues
there's always something else to it it's
never just study issues okay well you
have friends that do only fans you're
19. so you're young as hell
but you're in the modeling world you
have how many of your girls that you're
friends with associate with models that
you know are doing any sort of only Fan
sex work anything that would be
categorized in that not much not many no
not many okay